good morning believe nation today's
message is experiment over to you Ellie
Goulding it's key to everything
oh it's key to what I do I wouldn't be
here without experimenting like crazy I
I'd like to a different types of music
and I hope that I could get away with
including all of those different
influences it on my first record and I
think I got away with it and maybe my
second as well I mean like I would say
that I'm a pop artist I like pop music
but it's not without a lot of
experimentation and also you know
risking doing you know writing something
that maybe isn't very good or is oh it's
silly you know my voices might is my
instrument so sometimes I sing things
that just sound crazy but then like one
take out of 20 or be really really cool
and then I keep that one then that's
that
so yeah it's fermentation is everything
for me as a musician I think
experimentation is that the key to
success not just as a musician not just
as an entrepreneur but in in general in
life you need to experiment you need to
take the ideas that you have in your
head and go and try stuff because if you
are not experimenting then what's
happening then you're just living life
by the book you're just doing things
that other people tell you to do you're
doing the same things over and over and
over and over and over again
you're not trying anything new and so
your life becomes as boring repetition
day in and day out and that sucks
especially as a creative entrepreneur
who wants to grow and make a difference
so I want to address what I feel holds
people back from trying from
experimenting the first part is I think
people are just afraid of being judged
they're afraid of failing they're afraid
of putting themselves out there and
trying something new and it not working
out and people are going to laugh at
them or bheem and they're gonna be
embarrassed and that is not the way to
live your life if you look at successful
people the further and further I had
they
right the more and more success they
have you'll find that those super
successful people they don't care about
how other people perceive them I am not
doing what I do because I'm worried
about other people's judgments and the
people were at the bottom the people who
never get ahead the people who
continually struggle are the ones who
are always afraid of how other people
are going to judge them you're going to
make mistakes you will try things that
will not work out and the key is you
need to start building that muscle you
have to start building that
experimentation muscle because when you
put something out there and it doesn't
work what happens is you grow stronger
when you take an idea from your head and
you put it out there and you try every
time you do that you grow stronger every
time you care a little bit less about
somebody else's opinion of you you grow
stronger and you have a choice every
single day every single day you have a
choice to either grow stronger or shrink
back down every time you get an idea and
you do something about it even if it
doesn't work you grow stronger you build
that muscle so you could do it again and
next time with more power every time you
get an idea and you don't do something
about it and you shrink down and you
tell yourself why you can't do it and
you're worried about other people's
judgments then you get weaker and you
reinforce that story either way you're
reinforcing a story to yourself that you
can do this and you can be strong or you
can't do this and you're weak and every
day you have an opportunity to reinforce
either story and I want you to start
playing here I want you to start feeling
like you are powerful I want you to stop
caring about what other people think of
you and I want you to start when you get
an idea doing something about it and it
doesn't just happen overnight at least
from my experience it doesn't just like
you know what tomorrow I don't care what
anybody thinks of me you could say that
but actually believe it I don't know but
you can do it in steps you may not be
able to go and lift this huge weight but
you can work your way up there and every
day you get a little bit stronger and so
every little tiny micro win is still a
way
that makes you stronger unless you move
one step forward the second thing about
experimentation I think holds people
back is they feel it has to be perfect
it has to be the perfect thing it has to
be all worked out before they ever get
started and that is not the path what
you have to understand is most of the
learning that you'll get most of the
figuring out what it's gonna be
comes from actually trying it whatever
idea you have you can't just come up
with it in your head and write it down
on a piece of paper you have to go out
and start doing it and you'll learn by
the doing of how to adjust this was an
example one of my instructors here at
Toronto dance salsa wanted to practice
storytelling in our classes so instead
of just coming in and teaching how to do
a turn in salsa she's given a story
around it maybe it's her own story of
how she learned that maybe it's another
student's story about how they learned
it and difficulties that may have had
and how they came through it because her
goal and being an instructor here is not
just to teach people how to be dancers
and learn a certain move but to build
people's confidence to strengthen their
soul to become better humans to take
what they learn here the feeling they
get and had that have a ripple effect
out on the rest of their life that's
their goal that's what she wants for her
students she wants to be one of the best
instructors of all time for her students
because she had a profound impact on
their life and not just teaching them
subject matter and so she experimented
she had this idea she did something
about it and at the start it wasn't
working so well her stories were long
they mean it had the right theme it was
hard for people to understand
she was summarizing instead of going
deep into the material it wasn't a great
first start but this to be expected and
she got some feedback and there was one
particularly harsh message that came
from one of the students that said I
would rather go with this other
instructor because this one is you know
spending too much time storytelling and
I'm not getting value from it and I
showed it to her and it was really
really you know hard to take in because
when you know that you're not doing a
good job and then somebody shows it to
you right here's what this person said
it can be really hard but to her credit
she didn't stop and she kept working and
she kept getting better
and she can't practice and if she kept
adjusting and she continued to
experiment to the point where earlier
this week she had an amazing class one
where everybody left on such a high that
they're gonna remember for the rest of
their week rest of their month maybe
rest of the year that class that they
had with her and she transformed in that
class from just being a dance teacher to
somebody who's having a profound impact
on the lives of her students and that
happens in everything that you do you
are going to suck at the start expect it
that's okay but don't let that hold you
back from trying and experimenting you
go out there you try something you
adjust you get better you tweak it you
see if you like it so many of you have
these plans in your head are these great
ideas that you have when you do nothing
with them get them out and try stop
worrying about what people think
build that muscle to get stronger and
realize that the learning comes from the
doing not just the thinking so the
question is a today is I'm curious what
are you guys experimenting with right
now that's pushing you to be better
that's pushing through some limiting
beliefs you might have what's the
hardest thing you're experimenting on
right now leaving the comments below
I'm gonna join in the discussion I also
want to give a quick shout out to North
Santo Nora thank you so much for picking
up a copy of my book your one word I
really really really really appreciate
it and I hope you're enjoying so thank
you guys so much for watching I believe
in you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso
hey believe nation if you want a little
bit more inspiration on experimenting I
think these bonus clips will help you I
stopped listening to music after Kurt
died because it was so emotional just
hearing it I didn't want to hear it on
the radio I didn't want to play it I
didn't want to join another band and and
then after a while I realized that it
was the one thing that was gonna help me
get through everything so I started
writing lyrics I started writing songs
and I went and recorded this demo tape
it's on
a record company called and said hey we
want to release your record I said with
what that's a demo that's not a band
it's the thing I did by myself in five
days and you played every instrument
yeah so then I started to think wow
maybe I will try this I've never been
the center of a band was it a tough
transition from drama to front
absolutely hmm it took years man it took
a long time it's an interesting the way
it starts there's some moaning at the
beginning which makes it which one the
first song in the record birthday don't
know the titles no one told me the
titles just heard the record what is it
called exclusive birthday yeah you say
birthday in a lot but that's a very
mature progression sonically to add
those kind of moaning sounds as opposed
to being that the Disney person you
you've been known to be over the years
sure but I mean I'm not nothing
yeah yeah no no I think I think more I
think it's more me being able to
experiment you know being going into the
booth and actually having the confidence
of being like alright let me try this
let me see if this works and messing
around with melodies or just harmonies
or as you say moaning is that what it is
I guess that's the right term for it in
a way but um ya know I think in a way I
really was able to just play and then
that was fun you write in your book cuz
you're talking to the Arctic writing you
say imagine riding and planning routes
and everything you say magic exists but
often requires something but you were
talking about writing I think it also it
seems to also apply to the music even
like you have some planning but then
there's that well said absolutely so
yeah all that effort of study and I was
that the early records that the three of
us made together we were experimenting
we were learning how to play our
instruments we were learning how to
write songs we were learning how to
arrange especially through I'm say
farewell to King's hemispheres we were
learning so much about arrangement and
orchestration in the sense of a
three-piece rock band and all of that
gathered together and then by say my
moving picture of 1980 so we've been
together six years by that time and then
we gelled and and all of those studies
all those courses of study that we went
through together
with pure innocence and pure enthusiasm
suddenly they became a unified approach
that moving pictures and from then on
carried for us and then as that time
even from that time yeah we continued to
experiment absolutely with different
kinds of songs different kind of
arrangements orchestrations of all kinds
different producers there's another good
example you can get comfortable working
with the same producer and then some
people do their whole career but we
always felt we wanted a new brains to
pick and new criticisms new enthusiasms
just new new opinions in late 2012
I worked on a book launch for Tim
Ferriss he wrote a book called the
4-hour chef it was his third book it was
published by Amazon and because it was
published by Amazon we found out at the
very last minute about six weeks before
launch that it was gonna be banned by
every major bookstore in the United
States and this is pretty much the worst
thing that can happen to you if you were
doing a traditional book launch because
that's where books are sold so how do we
hit the New York Times bestseller list
how do we move copies if all the
traditional marketing stuff is out the
window that that leaves growth hacking
right how do we do this how do we treat
this book like a startup that we're
creating from nothing one of the first
things we did was a was a BitTorrent
giveaway where we gave away something
like 250 pages of the book videos photos
all sorts of extra stuff it ended up
getting downloaded I think about three
million times that drove 250,000 people
to the Amazon page it was the single
most effective thing I've worked on
close to a dozen bestsellers it was the
single most effective thing that I've
ever seen in the history of book
marketing and it came from giving a
sizable portion of the book away and and
so it was it was this proof for me that
the traditional marketing the the the
untrackable the untested things aren't
working anymore and that we want to
experiment when we want to try new
things